joe biden was asked about his vaccine
um roll-out plan and
here's how that i think we're going to
get a lot of exchanges like this
but here's how that exchange went
up
[Music]
where the u.s is right now when i
announced that you all said it's not
possible come on give me a break man
it's a question good start 100 million
so he was asked about this plan to give
100 million vaccines and the report was
well maybe we should be giving more than
that is that enough
and joe biden's answer is come on man
give me a break and then he just gets up
and leaves
that's why that's the answer
um meanwhile the media has
consistently claimed that biden is
starting from scratch he's
talking about the the vaccine rollout
plan well the claim we've heard from
from the media many times over the last
couple days and this exact phrase
they're starting from scratch because
trump hadn't done anything
even though he had operation warp drive
and they were it
certainly seemed like there's plenty
being done but the media said no no
nothing was done starting from scratch
he's got to do it all himself
well dr fauci was asked about this at a
press conference and here's what he said
just ask you about the effort to
distribute the vaccines because of
course
that's what makes people want to know
when are they going to get a vaccine
is the biden administration starting
from scratch
with the vaccine distribution effort or
are you picking up where the trump
administration left off
no i mean um we certainly are not
starting from scratch because there is
activity going on in the distribution
but if you look at the plan that the
president has put forth
about the things that he is going to do
namely get community vaccine centers up
get pharmacies more involved where
appropriate
get the defense production act involved
not only
perhaps with getting more vaccine but
even the things you need
to get a good vaccine program for
example
needles and syringes that might be more
useful than that
yeah by the way it's operation warp
speed i'm informed not warp drive
warp drive that's that's some that's
that's a little different that's star
trek i think
so i didn't get a little confused anyway
um so not starting
not starting from scratch there there
was obviously already something in place
but so fauci said that but he also said
something else which is uh he was he was
on cnn i think a little bit later that
day
it was earlier today same day um when he
agreed that
the according to him the the supposedly
the dishonesty from the trump
administration led to people
dying uh let's let's listen to that clip
so the white house released its new
coronavirus strategy yesterday and they
came out with this 21-page
summary of it and the number one thing
the number one goal
of the new buying white house in terms
of battling the pandemic
is to restore trust with the american
people
why is it necessary to say that
well i think that that was really good
making that number one because what
we've had
john there's no secret we've had a lot
of divisiveness we've had
facts that were very very clear that
were questioned
people were not trusting what health
officials were saying there was great
divisiveness
masking became a political issue so what
the president was saying right from the
get-go
you know let's reset this let's
everybody get on the on the
on the same page trust each other let
the science speak and he said that
multiple times
did the lack of candor did the lack of
facts
in some cases over the last year cost
lives
you know it very likely did you know i
don't want that john to be a sound bite
but i think if you just look at that you
could see
that when you're starting to go down
paths that are not based on any science
at all and we've been there before i
don't want to
rehash it that is not helpful at all
i don't want it to be a sound bite but
uh here's a sound i don't want to give
you a sound bite but here's one
of course that's a sound bite he damn
well knows it
we want to talk about lack of candor uh
what about from fauci himself
who who was among the people early on
saying
you don't need to wear a mask all of our
sacred public health experts and
officials
not just um not just donald trump
early on saying you don't need masks
and now they say uh if you don't wear a
mask you know you're killing people
now i i my personal opinion is that they
were
more right the first time but according
to what they're saying now
if you believe what they're saying now
then that means
that people like fauci and any other
public health experts that don't wear a
mask early on
they're responsible for killing people
according to what they're saying now
but of course there's there's no
accountability for that whatsoever